Magnificent, marvelous—legendary.
Undulating as gracefully through the vast
sky above as the watery depths below,
the Chinese dragon is one of the world’s most
globally recognized monsters. Their behavior
could be described as benevolent—but their
appearance can still inspire fear and awe.
These dragons, or long, as they’re
called in Chinese Mythology,
have been a crucial component of religion,
culture, mythology, and folklore in China for
thousands of years. The dragon is one of the Four
Benevolent Animals in Chinese mythology and one
of the twelve members of the Chinese zodiac. And
those are only small parts of their influence.
Dragons played a major role in China’s history.
They were both creators and destroyers,
and controlled the elements.
So what was it about the Chinese Dragon that
made it such a central figure in Chinese culture?
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka, and this is Monstrum
The dragon was born in China a long time ago,
and has appeared throughout ancient and modern
history. Cave carvings in the Shanxi province
depicting the creature date back to 8,000 BCE.
A Jade Dragon discovered from the Hongshan culture
dates to around 6,000 years ago. And dragon
heads appear on oracle bones from 1300 BCE. More
recently, Disney’s Shang-Chi gave us a beautiful
(and mythologically accurate) representation of
the creature. That’s a pretty solid track record.
Wang Fu, a Chinese historian and philosopher
in the Eastern Han Dynasty wrote that the
dragons’ unique appearance is actually a
composite of many different animal features.
And the list is long! Their heads are the same
shape as a camel, their ears are like a bull,
and they regard us with eyes similar to a hare
or a murderous demon, depending on the source.
Atop their majestic heads grow the antlers of
a stag. They have the writhing body of a snake
and the well-armored belly of a clam. They have
the feet of a tiger and the enormous talons of
an eagle. Finally, covering their whole body are
the protective scales of a carp. Some scholars
believe that these various attributes evolved
out of the influence of the disparate tribes
that eventually unified into the China we know
today. Others see them as emblematic of desirable
human characteristics or as a representative
amalgamation of ancient spiritual totems.
Some traditions claim that Chinese dragons conceal
a large pearl in their throat or chin. The pearl,
often depicted in art as a glowing
white disk in a dragon’s claw or mouth,
may represent the sun, the moon, or the
earth. Or maybe it’s just a giant jewel.
Regardless, the dragon’s ability to hold
the precious orb represents immense power.
Even the number of scales on the Chinese
dragon’s body carries important significance.
The number is said to be 117 which in traditional
Chinese philosophy and religion represents a
perfect balance of yin (negative essence) and
yang (positive essence). Because of this natural
duality, while usually compassionate,
the dragon can be malicious as well.
Or even just really invested in politics. In
the 17th century, scholar Xie Zhaozhe’s text
The Five Assorted Offerings tells the story of
his own encounter with dragons. According to Xie,
while traveling by sea at 10-years-old with
his uncle on a diplomatic mission, they were
suddenly plagued by wind, rain, hail, thunder,
and lightning. Three dragons surrounded them.
At first, everyone was terrified
of the extraordinary creatures.
But an elder remarked that they must
be there to hear the Emperor’s message.
They interact with gods and
immortals in the heavens.
Even without wings, they can fly through the
air. They are shapeshifters, capable of taking on
any size or shape—including human form. They can
turn invisible at will, are highly intelligent,
in some stories they can even speak.
The deep meanings attributed to Chinese
dragons are ancient, so much so that their
exact origins are largely lost to the past.
The evidence that we do have, however,
suggests dragons were a universal facet in
all early cultures in China even though
traditions and spiritual significance differed.
In The Guideways through Mountains
and Seas, an encyclopedic
tome and Chinese bestiary penned
between the 4th and 1st century BCE,
the dragon appeared as a nature
deity known as the God of Thunder,
who uses his own belly to drum up echoing booms.
There were even so-called “Dragon cults,”
religious groups that worshipped dragons
and gave offerings to appease them.
As aquatic, semi-divine beings dragons control
rainstorms, hail, wind, tornados, floods, and all
bodies of water. Dragons helped explain the
rain cycle during the Song dynasties and
were thus also said to bring thunder and
lightning. This was an important development
because if humans could summon dragons, then they
had a semblance of control over rain as well.
During this same period, paintings
of dragons dramatically increased.
In Ancient Chinese cosmology there are four kinds
of dragons: the Celestial Dragon, Dragon of Hidden
Treasure, the underground or underworld dragon
and spiritual Dragon who control rain and winds.
But in other traditions, the taxonomy expands
to nine, an auspicious number in Chinese
numerology—and, interestingly, the same number
of animals the dragon borrows its features from.
Joining the classification system are
the Winged Dragon , the Horned Dragon,
the Coiling Dragon, the Yellow
Dragon, and the Dragon King.
The Dragon King concept was only introduced after
thearrival of Buddhism in China. When Buddhism
came to the area, dragons were adopted as a symbol
ofenlightenment as well as royalty. Buddhism was
then imported from China to Japan around the
7th century, and dragons came along with it.
Dragons were later incorporated into Shintoism as
well. The Shinto god Susanoo was believed to have
killed an eight-headed dragon—which certainly
seems like a monster-slayer story to me.
In Chinese mythology, when the four poles that
held up the sky collapsed one of the disastrous
consequences was great flooding brought on by
the Black Dragon, a malevolent creature who
could only be stopped by the mother goddess Nüwa.
But other dragons are not so monstrous; after all,
one of those world-building pillars
was constructed by the Green Dragon,
one of the deities of creation. In yet
another creation story from the Bai
peoples, when the world was created, a great
golden dragon lay in slumber under the sea.
When one of two warring suns dropped into
the ocean, the sea began to boil. Awoken and
enraged by this, the golden dragon swallowed the
sun. It began to burn him, eventually bursting
from his chest and becoming clouds, trees,
flowers, grass, and animals of all kinds.
So to sum it up, not all Chinese dragons are
the same, they serve different purposes. Some
are celestial, others belong to the river, some
protect treasure, act as deities, or serve as a
connection to the spiritual. Oh, and they can have
human offspring–or more specifically, emperors.
This is one reason why Chinese dragons are
intimately linked to imperial history. During
the Han dynasty to Qing dynasty period, the
great and powerful dragon became associated
with emperors as a way to show the rulers had
been divinely chosen. The first Han emperor,
known as the Yellow Emperor, was said to be the
offspring of a human mother and a divine Dragon.
This supposed heritage trickled down to all
elements of the emperor’s authority, from their
robes to their beds. Yellow or golden dragons
were particularly revered by imperial powers.
And the five-clawed dragon became an official
imperial symbol in the 14th century. Their claws
represent the emperor’s power over the five
elements: wood, fire, earth, metal, and water.
Eventually, everyone else was banned from wearing
any clothing that pictured a five-clawed dragon.
That’s not to say that all stories of
dragons were based on mythology, animism,
or legend. Ancient animals likely played a role
as well. Yep, we’re talking dragons and fossils.
As early as China’s Jin Dynasty, which lasted
from 265 to 317 CE, we find a text mentioning
the discovery of what were believed to be
dragon bones in what’s now Sichuan Province.
A lot of the sediment in this area dates back
to the middle and late Jurassic period, and the
area is full of fossils. Remains of dinosaurs
like the predatory theropods were found there,
as well as a massive sauropod with an extremely
long neck that could grow up to 25 meters long.
Dragons inhabit exotic spaces: mysterious watery
depths, expansive skies, and heavenly realms.
Their powers are frightening but inspirational,
and they’re beautiful in their
strength and otherworldliness.
Luck, power, wisdom, bravery, strength—Chinese
dragons inspired everything from religious
practices to the national emblem, countless
astounding artworks and architectural marvels
to the globally famous dragon dance. The
creature is inseparable from the history of
the Chinese people. To embrace the Chinese
dragon is to celebrate Chinese culture.
Thanks for watching. Let me tell you a little
about Subcultured, a brand new documentary series
from PBS that focuses on lesser known communities
and folx that have a major impact on the
mainstream. What can somebody who is completely
blind teach you about video games? How did anime
become a $25 billion dollar industry? Check it out
over on PBS Voices and tell them DR. Z sent you.